there's no even place for them to
practice and they all said you're not
going to make it cuz you're black and
then they were like just watch meon
that's in the movie yeah it's a
[Music]
quote and welcome back to another
episode of JK reviews or JK reviews oh
cool what are we reviewing today we're
reviewing the following video okay so
we're going to watch it together and
then we're going to oh is that a runner
review it here we go this is a runner
okay she looks like she's sweating or
tired she's running in the rain is she
running a marathon it's in the rain very
emotional is she barefoot no is she oh
it's
raining she's thinking people wow did
she get run over
bro she's giving a flag or it's a
Cambodian it's Cambodian Cambodian y
Cambodian crying I wonder what event
that are you guys ready for the twist
they're
she's in last
place what's the twist though this is is
this inspiring or not but why why was
she so thankful for being on the last
place you tell me brother hey sometimes
when you didn't think you could finish
and then you finish that you thankful
you know it's all about the context of
what it took for her to get to that that
wasn't a 100 yard dash was it it was
yeah what was the event look is she a
stinking loser yeah she's a stinking
loser but is it cool that she finished
her race yeah 5,000 m 5,000 m yeah I
don't know I think I don't think that's
very long miles three miles 3 miles yeah
so that means she's so last that no one
was even there anymore and they everyone
they were already dressed in the locker
room the other way home they're all gone
they're all dry by the way imagine you
do that race and then you get laughed a
bunch I think halfway through you're
like should I just even finish this
[__] race you're probably contempla
and it's raining on you I mean
everyone's just not even watching
wouldn't the rain help you more cuz you
cool down that's what I was saying and
and you're sliding most of the time I
guess in empathetic way a good like an
interesting story is a story right like
nobody's going to give a [__] if out of
10 Runners if you're like fifth sixth
seventh or eighth right at least 10th is
still there if there's some concept of
excitement to it at least it's an
interesting enough thing to follow so if
she like through the struggle and being
last place at least still finished and
she's emotionally like satisfied with it
it's like oh good for you is there like
an element to it where like she [__]
had endometriosis or some [__] nah she
just lost the race big time she's just
like insanely
slow yeah oh yeah well she has blow she
faced low blood blood pressure during
the the the run so she should have ate
what she should have ate a
mango I was waiting I was waiting for
you guys to talk bunch of [__] and I was
going to say that but so she she did she
could have had a mangle I still don't
know what that means though what does
that mean low blood pressure I pressure
pressure ate a sandwich why are you have
why are you the one with a fobby accent
out of all low blood pressure is a
disposition no low blood pressure she
she could have do a Daran a mango a
coconut water while she's ready so she's
like that's not from like some kind of
condition that she has normally it's
just um it just says she faced low blood
pressure during the 5,000 m at the
Southeast Asian Games trailing
significantly behind oh they bolded that
word huh yeah and then during uh a heavy
rainstorm but her determination to
complete the race endeared her to the
rest of her Nation uh I don't I don't
agree well is what I'm asking is this
inspiring is this inspiring I don't
think so that's why JK reviews it do you
know what I don't think it's
endearing it's like that's a requirement
you better finish the [__] race why
do a lot of people just go [__] it and
then they walk off stage that's what I'm
wondering it's like if you are losing
significantly like do people just like
stop on a long race or
something it says significantly it's a
big deal it says it that means it's a
big deal or maybe their country doesn't
have a David goggin cuz in our country
but you [__] [__] you better finish
yeah maybe I don't know I think if it's
whack it's whack like with the Filipino
diving team they're not good no they're
terrible whole yeah and they're just
like the worst diving team ever oh yeah
I saw that video it's really funny but
it's very rare that you'll find
Filipinos that are like no but they're
Filipino like no they're [__] making
fun of them too cuz it's funny is it
because she had like a pre-existing
condition and then so she overcame name
it or it's just she just randomly had L
says low blood blood pressure and there
was a storm blood pressure yeah but
everyone else got first place with the
storm too everyone got first place I
wonder what her final time was together
crossing the line at the same time all
nine of it was easy mode all nine at the
same time easy mode it was easy mode it
was Duke Duke him easy mode yeah I mean
you know the United Nations of [__]
Runners she's the only one left out yeah
I mean well look you have to admit I
that's a lonely clip I don't think you
see another human everyone left yeah
everyone's gone they're all up to they
all drove home they're all doing hurdles
in some other place now the meat's over
how was the last event it's over yeah I
don't know if that's inspiring then I
don't think so you know there's not even
lights on it cuz the packed up the
lights let's try to make the context
work maybe Cambodia never qualified for
these Southeast East Asian Games or
something like that and this is like the
first time even though they already knew
that she was going to get last because
her qualifying time was always slower
than the other nine countries maybe let
me tell you an inspiring story okay here
we go [__] Jamaican Bob slet team he
my egg cool running see there's no even
place for them to practice and they all
said you're not going to make it cuz
you're black and then they were like
just watch me man that's in the movie
yeah it's a quote yeah they're like
black people with a
sled so it wasn't cuz they're climate no
oh and they're like like we never seen a
black guy on a sled before and then
they're like y man we'll we'll see what
happens there at the race man Maurice
you're dead yet no man yeah bmba clut we
going to try at the race now man
inspiring though they actually won
imagine if they you watch the whole
movie and they got last
place that would have been great well
that's like remember I telling you guys
about that Australian uh speed skater
that everybody in front of him crashed
and fell and then he got first but he
was like way the [__] behind now he's a
motival speaker and and his motivational
speech is just like you know just keep
going cuz you never know just don't quit
that's what this is almost not really
because there still everybody else won
first hey she still got a headline this
still this is like in Mario Kart when
like your your your cart spins around
and you get blowed up cuz you didn't
place you got to go do it again I think
it's different if this is like a PE
class and like you're not supposed to be
a runner and you do that don't give up
but then if you made it to a level where
you're expected to excel you got to or
what if it was like her cousin made it
but then she got the measles so now she
has to go and take the place of her
cousin she never trade before but all of
Cambodia was like you have to do it for
us and she goes but I don't know how to
run and then there was like a training
sequence and she's training in Jamaica
dude she was training in Jamaica and the
Jamaican guys were like you can do it
you can do it believe in yourself and
then kiss my egg and then she did it and
then she failed and she was like why'
you guys set me up for failure but I'm
going to keep going so the thing that I
had tell you guys about this clip you
[__] is that all other 15 people she
was up against were born
men what why she racing against dudes
shut up female this is the female meet
yeah shut the shut up dude you got to be
[__] with us this isn't Thailand no
this isn't Thailand you're [__] with
us man take it okay fine if I take that
as truth then so it's a fe it's a female
race but all the other people
competitors were biological dudes every
other one of
them if only she could have said
that what are you talking about they're
all
chicks I'm confused man I don't know
what wouldn't that have been great then
it's like oh oh wow that's now Ben
Shapiro's talking about it this is why
we need to have women have women's Parts
this is why they should be allowed
motorcycles silly it's all context also
context to the country again no no shame
I have no idea the historical like
competition level of like Cambodia
specifically but if she was like a North
Korean Runner or something like that and
significantly fell behind or whatever
she's going to get her head shot when
you know what I'm saying her whole
family is going to be [__] put to the
ring right hypothetically there's rumors
I don't know Nick told me Nick Nick come
on D because she's like you know what I
mean maybe again I don't know like how
often does Cambodia get representation
in these positions you know like at that
point I feel like that could change the
whole Nar if it keeps going like this
not very often you think Cambodia wants
his representation they're like do they
have her scrub this fa Fair I'll stop I
feel like camb got a little more Pride
than like wanting people to coddle them
for getting last it must be the
performance though yeah they're good
they're good at some [__] objectively if
you look at a time and it's like last
place time you don't see any context it
you're like that person [__] lost but
if you saw the Spirit emulating as she
struggled to pass a finish now we're
reach dude pulling
theing if I got last placeing something
I reach over grab American flag and
start whipping it around and [__] people
be like this guy's an idiot yeah yeah
they'd be like he's [__] mental yeah
he's nuts did do they have her time I 5K
time it says three and 1 half hours shut
what no that you made that up three and
1 half hours you don't need 3 hours they
removed the bleachers by the time she
was done they had all the bleachers
broken down dude was running last plays
like that I would wish this would never
happen to me we like their camera's
still on me and they make a story out of
it why was she so emotional there's got
to be a reason no they weren't tears
they were uh raindrops rain oh really
Rain yeah but she was waving the flag
quite a bit all right I'm cover her from
the rain all right she she when the
[__] gun went off she slipped and
broke her ankle so she did the whole
race with a broken ankle all right there
we go fine right there no she's fine
though I mean
remember when Carrie strug got her
[__] leg [__] up and then she had
like the most perfect Vault she and she
still got first place and got first
place land on one flip mhm yeah it's
like that's kind of where you think the
emotion should be yeah at first place
speaking from a privileged
Nation hey vault's a vault in every
country dub is a dub dude first place is
first place the [__] are you talking
about you got second place I'm just
trying not to be high mind here okay
because that would kill our Channel
you're saying Cambodia should have 7
foot basketball courts or something I'm
just saying maybe she's like I'm the
only person in my family didn't open a
donut shop bro there got to be then
maybe you stick to Donuts yeah maybe you
should maybe you're on to something
cambodians are really good at fried
chicken and donuts really good got to be
a faster runner in Cambodia than if
you're in a race and the whole race that
you were running with like all the
people in the race are not there anymore
if everyone's taking na the bleachers
that's not good this is like this is
like when I read a news story when they
go this moment WNBA related inspired
America and I'm like it nobody that I
know talked about this this is
definitely going to be top five track
and field events of all time though they
probably I think this is also is also
even weirder to me because it's a very
un Asian result like to be like oh you
still did great you got last place you
can get it [__] that's not even the
Asian vocabulary I'm just guessing once
in a while you need even the loser story
to be inspiring so you're calling her a
loser how that you're the one who said
everybody else got first place
I heard it they did though everybody
else got first
[Music]
place